suffice to say after watching this film
I had a few sleepless nights what keeps
you up at night do you scare easily
yeah which is why I don't watch hard
lows um you know existential query I I
go through phases depends what's going
on and generally I mean I've got two
kids in a very full life so by the end
of the day when my head hits the pillow
I generally sleep pretty soundly yeah so
did your perception of the spirit world
change once he kind of does this film no
I've always been drawn to this kind of
thing because I'm interested in the
unspoken and the unknown I mean this is
not everything this physical temporary
existence that we have is is not it I
have a very real sense that that is the
truth there's so much more that we don't
know about and we are tiny specks of
nothing you know both vital and
completely unimportant and I loved that
this film you know I would never partake
in a Ouija board or you have seen
psychics and I think ultimately we all
have a sense of personal intuition that
you can tap in to or not but yeah I love
that this film really it was sent to me
as a genre film and I started reading it
and I didn't quite understand why they
were calling it that because it it kind
of felt just like this beautiful
meditation it's about a family grieving
you know and how the how the dynamics
change amongst them as they're
navigating something that's profound and
is painful and then very unexpectedly
once you've kind of invested emotionally
it takes a turn and I think Ari Astor
who wrote this and directed it is so
talented and has
such an original voice and I think in a
time when movies are being made for like
audiences on mass and it the voice
becomes watered down and becomes
unappealing to most people so yeah he's
just it this I think the strength of one
clear voice is actually what people
respond to because there's an honesty to
it and it's just truthful and that's
what we all really respond to what was
it like playing an E and hereditary
hereditary and then looking back
headland in the sixth sense two very
special films in their own ways
I mean they were completely different
experiences and that were decades apart
I guess people are drawing similarities
because both filmmakers made these films
earlier in their careers and then not
just a simple horror film there's
something that's it these films are like
classic dramas they're dealing with
something very profound and they're
doing it in a really honest interesting
way and there and and in an original way
last thing I'm obviously this is all
about what we inherit as families is
there a real-life tradition or trait
that your family tree has that you're
glad to however maybe not so glad to
have uh yeah I mean it's interesting
isn't it what you hope you and sometimes
you're not even aware of what you can
take from from your folks and your
bloodline I mean my family is pretty
easygoing there's a definite kind of
strong funny bone throughout my clan and
also we kind of get emotional quite
quickly quite sensitive
[Music]
yeah I'm happy with my Troy
[Music]